hi there steve here again we're week 8
of our 12 week 90 day challenge
and today i want to talk a little bit
about output in other words producing
the language now you know that
i believe along with stephen krashen
leading expert on language acquisition
that our
ability in the language will come
primarily from our input activities
listening and reading
occasional looking at grammar occasional
review of words and phrases perhaps a
focus on phrases all of this input
activity is building up our ability in
the language but all of us or most of us
want to be able to speak or write but
primarily speak and speak well so we
have to at some point start doing that
outputting the language
in the language now there are
opportunities that link that we have the
exchange where you can put text that you
start writing and have other members
correct them
and it is often easier to start writing
if you have the patience to write
because you have time to look things up
you have time to think about what you're
going to say obviously when you're
speaking you don't have so much time
so that's one place where you can start
but i think most of us
perhaps if i say
in my own case i'm a bit too lazy to
write i might write for example you can
write just even in your flashcards you
have that dictation function
where you hear it you have to write it
or you have
reverse flashcards where you have the
say english or whatever your native
language is and you have to produce it
in the target language but these are
minor things the main activity that we
kind of want to get into is speaking so
this means getting a tutor
and
where we have
tutors in those languages where we have
tutors that link i use our link tutors
where we don't have tutors
at link for some languages i have in the
past gone to italki but i prefer
to do it within link
i have good tutors for the languages
that i'm learning right now persian and
arabic
and the advantage is that we get a
report
with audio that we can listen to and so
here is the thing about our interaction
with the tutor
the interaction with the tutor is an
opportunity to speak of course you will
struggle
you will
simply not be able to remember words
that you thought you knew uh you'll make
mistakes in grammar that in fact you
know their mistakes almost even as
you're saying them incorrectly but you
just have to work your way through that
a good
tutor will give you a good list i get a
good list of the words and phrases that
i struggled with
and record them
and so this gives me then content that i
can review over and over again
and uh you know i might have 30 or 40 or
more of these conversation reports
in the languages that i've been learning
and so i can go back to a conversation
that i had six months ago and go over
some of those words and realize that in
fact i've already forgotten them and i
regularly do review so the output
activity
is not only an opportunity for you to
speak it's also an opportunity to create
more input activity than that you can
use because ultimately
the major sort of way in which you're
going to upgrade your language skills is
this commitment to ongoing
listening and reading input activities
increasing your vocabulary improving
your
comprehension skills this is the base
from which you will gradually develop
the ability to speak and the only way
you're going to speak better if you do
all of these other things is to speak
more
and that's going to mean more
interaction with your tutor or
if you have an opportunity wherever you
live as is the case with me in vancouver
there are a lot of persian speakers
where i live so if i go into a store
whether it be a persian grocery store or
even a department store and they have
staff there that are persian speakers
you can
you better believe that i'm going to
speak to them in persian
i didn't the level of my persian through
this 90-day challenge has improved to a
level where i can now engage with those
people so i'm certainly going to do that
and every time you do that
not only are you sort of discovering
where your gaps are which makes you more
alert when you listen and read
but it stimulates you it motivates you
and we all require motivation to stay on
task so
when it comes to output don't be
discouraged if you don't do as well as
you would like don't be discouraged if
you do well one time and do less well
the next time
i would also recommend that you focus a
lot of your listening activity and
reading activity on our mini stories
because i have found that they have
enabled me to start speaking much much
earlier because there is a lot of
repetition built around the most common
verbs in a language and we need to have
verbs in order to express our ideas
and in many languages the verbs create
have a lot of grammatical issues that
are difficult to get used to so i would
do a lot of listening and reading of the
many stories in preparation for
your output activities but ultimately
you have to get going don't second-guess
yourself just let it fly out of your
mouth
don't
try to remember the rules of grammar
just see rules of grammar see what
you're able to say
review your
conversation reports when you get them
back from your tutor
so go and explore the tutor section at
link look at who we have there that are
tutors in your language and see if you
can't find someone who is going to be to
your liking and if you don't like the
first one try another one so that's what
i have to say about output it's
two-thirds of the way through here
and it's time to start maybe doing a
little more output activity all right
thank you bye for now